yes I do not know what you broadcast
from our conversation but it might be
known in the meantime let that was
Mother's great hero of my eye I would
love to meet him but probably more
interesting for me would be the figure
of Nietzsche because I mean he was a
complete tormented figure who was so
horrifying prophetic about what would
happen to Europe his prophecy that we
would kill the Jews that Europe will be
in ruins capitalist society marks his
society he saw it all he saw it all and
then he said I accept it as a dish
ubermensch and so on and so forth i
meani I mean he ended you know in in
complete insanity and yet in his work in
his nose in his letters you know how you
can see how troubled he is that the son
of a preacher who first devoted his life
to do bad man and so on and so forth for
me he's one of the most fascinating
figures in European history so Nietzsche
probably yes because with him I could
disagree Thomas Mann and Socrates I
could only say yes yes yes you're right
you're right or I wonderful my
catchphrase for a lot of things is a
nobility of spirits because that's the
quintessence of you know of culture
socket estamos balance owns a phone
booth was also the case of each and I am
wondering and if in the end he believed
himself what he what he wanted to
believe it's very difficult because if
as he analyzed no there is no God no dry
no transcendental values no there is no
eternity notice there is only what water
is nothing else and yes we are animals
and we will behave like animals
and we have to accept a complete
meaninglessness of our society that
everything is trivial and so on and so
forth I don't know because we didn't
know he must have been he accepted it
and he saw the horror of it and and yet
in his in the person he was who was a
very honest a man who had a lot of
friendships for the French of us
enormously important it was also a kind
of inclination of the nobility of
spirits as a human being without a
cultivation of the human soul through
liberal education through knowing the
big ideas real values it's this process
of homecoming to our better self that's
what nobility of spirit is all about
including you know the questions and all
these it all these things and and and
also I'm in Jerusalem and and that you
don't give up the idea that that that
rough inch which are the best I mean one
of the problems for me with the more
ideological liberal side of our society
is that liberals more or less in a line
of Nietzsche has had we do no longer
know what the best is everybody for
should decide for themselves so but
there is one thing we know very well I
never thought is worst Judith's car
putting cruelty first and we are against
it and so we have human rights universal
human rights international organization
and so on and so forth now of course
this is of tremendous importance
graphics which we cannot allow and
accept anywhere in the world where ever
you are universal human rights but can
we build a society can we build a
civilized society without having a
knowledge of what is best can we really
I mean are we serious when we when we
really say to people look and wherever
you like Mozart or Britney Spears is
just a matter of taste I happen not to
believe in that
it's very complex it's not again so but
but but but but it's it's one of the end
and so the nobility of spirit takes as
one of the DD DD a premises that we must
know what is best now I cannot claim it
and so on and so forth but I have to
have that kind of knowledge